celebrities have recently been getting
tattoos on their faces right so the
first one Amber Rose disappointing those
are kids names she's so pretty why would
she do that why in the world well be
that super smart but what what is uh
it's her two sons names why would you do
that does Sebastian and slash on her
head her head she like actually did an
interview where she she basically said
that after Kobe died she realized that
life is short and that she should do
what she wants if you still could be on
the planet for another I don't know
fifty years were going to [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're gonna put you think Kobe you'd
want that yeah not about your kisses
it's more about you isn't it when you do
that yep anything embarrassing your kids
so there you go let's go ahead and see
her what she looks like nowadays so cuz
I'm happy with it
have you ever seen in person no really
she was a stripper right bring her up
really you don't say oh no that's not
her pregnant oh don't click are there
either how about that when she went
chocolate a weird that's by China yeah
black China that kind of seems
well-adjusted there tier now is that
what's used to look like this is her
right here that's Chloe right yes well
oh there she is there's like her take
that for a spin be yeah I'm not there's
been a few rappers have busted with that
yeah that was a few yeah she a white
girl or she mix what is she I believe
she's Creole well there you go
grill well I appreciate it Creole yeah
me she's a big girl
don't is that her boyfriend that that
dude that's nice of you can't come to
her life you can't come to her life yeah
you're too light be yeah you gotta come
beliefe but that is wiz khalifa sheikha
looks like he's working on the bucket on
the warhammer is that lungs it makes
noise I think you can feed a cop cause
oh yeah I think a [ __ ] that thing's
gotta be rules yep
what else got yes she's all just a few
others so this is Chris Brown he had a
Nike Jordan Jordan tattoo on his face
what are you doing he's such a good
looking bright
what do you think my sneaker head but
unless Jordans pay me a billion dollars
a year about you why are you getting a
[ __ ] sneaker on your face everyone's
doing it and then you're a girl Cindy
Crawford her son this is a model he got
a tattoo oh but you got misunderstood oh
no - it on his chin no that's what this
kid that's Jenny Crawford's son mm-hmm
do you think about when you're 45 and
your face that's misunderstood your kids
like dad what happened
good-looking kid billionaire well he's
not billing no daddy is what well bit
he's definitely not and there's gonna be
some issues there yeah no that's this is
statement if I thought this was going to
ruin my face or I didn't want this I
wouldn't have done it I think that's a
pretty obvious thing and Danny goes okay
I love it by the way look at these
[ __ ] haters out here [ __ ] you if you
don't like it I mean it is his choice if
he wants to do it looks good yes I won't
mean I just won't even cross my mouth
when I leave the studio all I'm saying
is you [ __ ] up lucky kid he's a model
what that's not me but you can't mm-hmm
all right yeah on the face dude yeah
I've never got I don't get it well is it
Elizabeth Hurley who has the the son
who's he looks like a girl yeah very
pretty pretty who's this
remember Elizabeth Hurley sorry yeah
that's a pretty fella
mmm all right well whatever all right
dude let's get more choice bro no I'm
just we could I embody the hold on so
how is this it's spelled just kung fu
kung fu' what you're saying golf well
that's how it's said so as I'm from I
studied in China pistol